In this exercise, I've set-up two viewports on the screen. A perspective view
and a top view orthographic camera. I should mention there's one extra thing to
set on the renderer in 3JS, when using multiple viewports, renderer autoclear
equals false. This setting tells 3JS to not clear the screen before rendering
the viewport. The top view works by defining the volume and space. The up
vector for the view is set, somewhat arbitrarily, to be the plus x axis. During
rendering the camera position itself is set to be up one unit, looking down at
the target. The idea is to look at the target and then move back a bit to
establish the look at direction. Note that the look at and up directions should
never be parallel. Your task is to add two more viewports. Add a front viewport
to the upper left, side the the lower right. The front viewport should look up
along the positive x axis, the side viewport down along the negative z axis.
Both the front and side viewports should track the target position similar to
how the top viewport works. When you're done, the program should look like
this.